I think it's normal to feel some guilt
when you're eating a turtle did you eat
the tail you suck the hole
um
well because I can only the only thing
but it kept on sucking it back in and
playing peekaboo with me
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys
where we are currently hey we're off the
record I think we are I had a feeling we
were and uh we have um yeah we're all
here everybody's here
[Applause]
all right here's the question what is
the weirdest thing you've ever eaten
the weirdest stinky tofu recently was
born oh that's watch that video
it was pretty weird what did you think
were you like it was like eating
halitosis yeah when you said that I was
like yeah it is it really is
100 it's like a little brick of
halitosis like I eat a lot of crazy [__]
and I get used to things but I can't get
used to stinky tofu man because it
really just smells like someone wiped
their ass out of tofu and left it on the
plate yeah sweaty but it is it is kind
of like it's so bad and you think when
you taste it it's like oh it's gonna be
a different but it's not really
different I like Orion's first bite
because he was sitting next to me and he
puts in his mouth I was like and he's
like
um yeah
I guess he didn't try to like hold like
be polite and like I don't want to
disrespect Bart's culture he was trying
to be polite while a tear was [__]
forming and it's crying dude was that
your first time yeah I was super
emotional it was super emotional
I wasn't I wasn't sure of the because
you know when you know somebody's grown
up eating it you have no idea if they
even know that it's tastes like [__]
like yeah they might think like oh it's
very good like please try it yeah I
remember I was at the 626 night market
and then like you know how they had some
stinky tofu booths that only did that
[__] oh yeah
it almost died because I was like they
have no idea what that's yeah they don't
know yeah man someone took the [__]
around here
it really is like a super Versa though
oh dude and they have all the stick at
the 66 Night Market they have all the
stinky tofu spots like on one edge of
the corner yeah but it still makes the
entire night market smell like did you
eat grow up eating it not really not
much but we've had it but it's
definitely not something that like were
you able to do it though kinda but you
know what's crazy you sound like you're
resisting game hello in Taiwan though a
little bit they have full on rest
restaurants that only serve that damn
yeah and it'll be like two stories tall
and it's not even like uh like imagine
like you know when you go to a burger
place they have other stuff like hot dog
or french fries or whatever there are
stinky tofu places that only have stinky
tofu nothing else no dumplings or any
other accessory dish it's only a stinky
tofu place I just love the idea that
somebody's like this is legit and all
this stuff and they're like [__] Panda
Express that's not real [__] Chinese
food like stinky tofu that's what the
[__] is up that's the good [__] it's
like yeah dude go ahead cram it up your
[__] ass already dude the only person
who believes this [__] is you while
you're on camera with the record on
right and that's it there was an episode
of Bizarre Foods where Andrew goes up
and to that to the in Taiwan and it's
it's not um fried it's just tofu and
then they put a sauce on I never even
tried that one before that was awesome
and it's supposedly it's like one of the
oldest stinky tofu plates it looks crazy
though because the tofu is great yeah oh
yeah it looks like Dead brain
I like the more legit it is the more
whack it looks no but it's like really
the worst of the stickier it is well
this is authentic yeah it has a light
dust on it oh that's way more authentic
dust I mean my bib give me my bib please
the chef is old it's legit
almost all the food that I found gross
when I first tried it I've learned to
like it and I think like trying
different foods that different cultures
like it's like a um it's like being able
to experience their world yeah right and
I
I really want to get to know stinky tofu
but that's one thing that I just can't
[__] do but everything else like like
when I got introduced to chicken feet or
duck feet I saw that [__] and I was like
dude this is like a pterodactyl's arm
yeah this is [__] disgusting or leg
but yeah or like just like Piggy or like
even Hainan chicken when I first saw
that thing
um our landlord brought it over me and
my mom we were like let's eat it for
dinner and then we looked at it and
we're like how do we eat this it just
looks like raw chicken like what do we
do and then we warmed it up oh it's like
steamed no it comes cold I kind of yeah
I think the real you're supposed to eat
it cold but it's chopped like all
carcassy looking yeah it they she
literally just gave us with the head
just [__] chopped up it's a whole
chicken yeah and then and then um I mean
I [__] go to town on that [__] now I
love it you know but when we first saw
it we were like yo it just looks like
raw chicken like I don't know what to do
you don't like dust covered tofu
Dusty tofu brought to you in a [__]
damp basket so like on a on a scale of
one to ten bar like how much do you
actually like to stinky tofu I actually
like it a lot when's the last time you
had some [__] it's so hard to get it
that's the thing
he just starts crying
he smells it
that's me yeah what's the least amount
of money you would have to accept to eat
it again
oh I I don't know 50 bucks it wasn't
that big a deal
why would you even name a price it
wasn't
a lot of weird [__] like bugs and dog
food that's that's what I mean [__] like
that you have to pay me isn't that whole
thing on Tick Tock right now where Jim
Bros are eating [__] dog food because
it's high in protein that's crazy people
are dumb as [__] that's hilarious they
have protein shakes like they already
have like the best stuff yeah but they
were they're min max
they found a little hat it's a thing
right now a bit more yeah not toys I'm
so glad I'm not on but I'd eat a dry
[__] Cricket before I eat sticky tofu
as a delicacy or as like a JK party joke
though like I'm talking about like food
buy yourself alone like eating would you
just eat it if you enjoy it or like
cultural Delicacies out of town with
taika you're watching a movie at home
and you order stingy I would order it
for sure yeah if there was a Taiwanese
place down the street I would for sure
order it oh because geotago wouldn't
even let you eat it around them huh
because they'll be like yeah it's gonna
ruin their day that's like how that's
like how hotels in certain areas in Asia
they have signs that say you can't bring
durian in there oh yeah oh durian yeah
that's another thing
um that sucks when it's not fresh but
when we had it in Malaysia I thought it
was pretty good durian I know a lot of
people hate durian but I can handle it
it's good but it's also just different
flavors of permanent marker oh permanent
marker pencil pens I know I liked it
when I was a kid some part of the
markers small [__] bomb though that's
what Jared does it stop it smells yeah
it's like gasoline very strong I mean it
tastes like garlic mango yeah you can
get dirty in shakes remember during
shakes they have that like Malaysia and
Singapore yeah the weirdest you're good
the weirdest [__] I ever ate Was a Teddy
gram with maggots on it
but you see the weirdest thing
I've rolling up my mom like she's a
[__] nutrition freak yeah so she
doesn't like it when I have snacks so
you're trying to prove a point by eating
with Matthew no so she would only make
her [__] whack-ass food that's
[__] like rock hard rice with like I
should make me these weird uh she used
to bake her own bread oh yeah the fruit
bread yeah the [__] stained glass
window Brad so all their shit's [__]
whack it's all the damn [__] so
hungry God damn what am I gonna eat so I
was just digging through the cabinets
and then I found some Teddy Grahams in
the back and I was like oh what's this
and I opened it but it was old and
there's a little bit of maggots and I
was like but I'm so hungry and I ate it
so you dusted the maggots off I clicked
one of them off and it landed on a
sticky tofu but it was like the the
texture was so weird that's not how
Teddy grams taste like so I didn't eat
it oh
let's let's not do dumb like childish
stuff let's do like actual cultural food
Delicacies you just said you didn't say
you added to it I don't know right now I
didn't think we were gonna get the Teddy
Graham maggots live live we ate live
octopus that was weird
we ate the bull test fried bull
testicles
are they pretty are they pretty well we
had it cold because it was like for a JK
party they're huge I heard like when you
deep fry obviously when it's deep fried
but like they taste like an earthy clam
you know huh it was it was just chewy it
was weird they deep fry it
[Music]
oh you know what's weird but this is
more weird because of presentation but
in China they serve pigeon but they
serve it in a bird cage remember that oh
Jesus oh [__] in a bird cave they serve
it in an actual like stereotypical
looking bird cage and it looks like it's
a pet bird but is it fried yeah it's a
cooked pigeon inside the bird cage and
they give it to you like this and they
open the little door and then they take
it out and serve it to you wow
presentation and it's not even like a
fancy thing it's like a regular
restaurant will do that that is a [__]
up presentation I like how they're like
you know we gotta we gotta be more
classy like like can you think of some
ideas and they're like how about a bird
cake
and then they're just waiting for the
pigeon and they're like oh look
[Laughter]
I would assume all the Asians have
definitely tried some weird [__] what's
the weirdest [__] you have to eat I mean
uh I would say chicken hearts let's play
for nothing compared to what you guys
eat huh chicken
I'm talking about eating chickens feet
and stuff chicken chicken hearts just
taste tastes like nuts oh we have
balloons a half-formed bird or duck
right yeah half form duck and you crack
it up conceptually it's pretty wild yeah
you got all this [__] like jamniotic
fluid it's weirder when the feathers are
already kind of developing so it's kind
of it feels like hairy and then usually
you get it kind of like lukewarm right
so it's like gelatinous a little bit and
then you bite into it and it's like half
egg white half bones but but when you
don't eat it like a ghetto Asian style
like newspapers but they put it on those
like actual nice little mini goblets and
you give you like one little teaspoons
and it's like you like your
sophisticated yeah it does make it a
little bit do you see the face though
yeah because if you see the face it's
still like I don't know how far it looks
like a straight A fetus yeah yeah the
funny you know what one thing I don't
really like about this whole balloon
thing is like whenever they have like
crazy food segments on like TV shows or
like on James Corden they're gonna use
balloon like that's like like Fear
Factor [__] and then all the Filipino
and Asians get mad at that but it's like
we think it's [__] crazy too yeah and
we still eat it but we do think it's
crazy just because you can see its face
did you see the expression before it
died like it's pretty wild but we're not
like it's like it's mid face between egg
and animals same thing like a high knife
chicken you'll still get the head there
yeah it's the idea that it's still in
the Shell like it didn't even get a
chance to develop yeah exactly it's the
idea that it never feels like you're
eating a kid
mid transitioning things you're eating a
exactly just the yolk of an egg you know
but it's like how do you even start
digging in like what do you go for it
you make a whole you sip the fluid and
then you take the rest I go and some
people put like pepper and salt on it
and [__] you have yeah
yeah you usually spoon it
yeah that's what I mean you put Tabasco
on it and [__] and you slurp it up kind
of yeah cocktail sauce on it yeah most
of the stuff The Taste doesn't freak me
out because it's very similar to
something I've already had before
exactly yeah but the look is what freaks
me the look is your texture is Big too
because it doesn't have furniture
I think I might have told some of you
guys just I had a whale steak in Norway
before you said it was a very endangered
well right yeah very endangered it was
actually a willy a very endangered whale
no but it's a I I couldn't process it
because you know it's a it's a mammal so
it's got like you know it's red meat so
a whale snake is actually red meat so it
comes out it looks like steak and the
texture when you put in your mouth is
exactly like a steak because exactly
like to say just tastes like fish so it
feels like your whole world just went
upside down I've had whale Sushi weird
hey look the meat though looks a little
purple like it it doesn't look red like
steak yeah when it's cooked though it
looks just like steak I had it wrong
yeah have you guys had ever had a plate
of caterpillars
ah all right dude say that earlier
that's Chinese say that two minutes
that's Chinese that's more like Timon
and Pumbaa I didn't eat it but uh when I
was in junior high I went back to China
with my pops and he goes oh we got to go
back to like my hometown and then they
there's like a big family reunion
because like all the family from the US
is back and this is they brought out the
caterpillars huh yeah this is like some
country bumpkin [__] it's not like like
if you have family in the city it's like
oh they came back oh they're gonna come
back every year this is the relatives of
the relatives so even if the the
relatives in the city come visit the
country relatives they get excited so
that's why they were that excited when
my dad came because he was like oh [__]
the American is coming back so they
brought out a whole [__] without
spread supposed to be a [__] Feast
but they came out with a plate of
caterpillars and I was like oh my God
they probably been searching for months
man
preparing for your dad to come back stir
fry silkworms yeah
yeah but I was 13. yeah and I was like I
need to go find a McDonald's man this is
[__] crazy you know what's weird it's
like I'll eat like sea snails right it's
kind of the same [__] yeah like but then
when it comes to caterpillars and slugs
and something freaks me the [__] out and
I eat escargot like I'll eat a snail but
for some reason man I don't know like
the idea of a caterpillar that's just
discrimination and there's something
about things in the sea that feel kind
of clean a little bit
caterpillar just walking around in cat
[__] and stuff I don't know man there's
so much catching there but we eat things
like shrimp which are like Bottom
Feeders yeah that's true that's shrimp
it's like cockroach of the sea yeah but
we eat the [__] up you guys made shrimp
Daddy yeah when I was like eight years
old my mom broke her leg and so my dad
had to start cooking and my dad made us
lasagna Hamburger Helper and that was
[__]
whacked with a bomb though that was
absolutely I used to love him maybe the
way he did it it was disgusting he did
it wrong [__] kind of relate did you
did you ever have Turtle I think yeah
the whole Turtle yeah yeah
that seems like a red ear slider or like
a soft shell snapping turtle oh it was
the kind of turtle is it well after it's
cooked the Shell's a little bit soft I
gotta say that but it's it they the way
they serve it is the whole actual Turtle
it's the whole thing and honestly it's
kind of good yeah wow what does it taste
like I don't want to say chicken because
that's easy but it kind of tastes a
little bit like chicken but like the
type of flavoring it's it's not it's not
it's not that it tastes like it's
because the type of flavoring that they
use the seasoning is like a really
really Brown Saucy thing but I I went so
I went to my dad's relatives house in
China where they also [__] serve
turtle and [__] when we go oh my dad's
we're gonna stay here for a week I'm
gonna open his bathroom and I go in the
bathroom and I saw that the shower was a
trash can filled with water oh like it's
about to be I've done that before that's
at my dad's old house yeah this is gonna
be yeah you know what's crazier same
thing but like our house no that's for
the shower but I could just tell the
cuisine this week is gonna be some wow
here's a washing going to places like
that because saying my dad grew up in a
[__] ghetto ass area too and you
would go to the Outhouse which would
just be a little hole in a [__]
Outhouse that's built that's like has
still over like the the brown ass muddy
stream yeah and so you sit there and you
see the cat eat the [__] and then you
would still fish for the cat catfish and
eat the fish yeah fish for the catfish
yeah so like it's the [__] circle of
life you know what I mean I was like man
this place is [__] Rush when we were
in China they the dude was like all
right you guys want to get some food
we're like yeah so they're passing the
phone and people just pick what they
want and we got the phone and it was all
Turtles like the whole thing so it's
like internal McDonald's it looked like
when you look through nft Collections
and it's just different like slightly
different types no everything's a turtle
bro they're like yeah it's an old Turtle
restaurant
yeah come on bushy guys spicy frog legs
is good but [__] is that like the KFC
like that's so normal to them yeah
there's like some kind of restaurant
that is nothing but different kinds of
turtles for like years of scrolling
you're like what the [__] well you're
like you got you just got like a french
fry or something you know and they're
all like slightly different colors and
like different types of turtles when you
had your turtle you ate it like knife
and fork like you cut off yeah you like
Fork out the meat from like the shell
and you cut the Paw off and you ate it
kind of and it tasted good it was kind
of good
you have the guilt of like but it looks
yeah I think it's normal to feel some
guilt when you're eating a turtle did
you eat the tail you suck the hole
um
well because I can only the only vegan
related to it was a crab right because
I'm trying to bite the head it kept on
sucking it back in and play a [__]
peekaboo nobody gave a crab like you
open you suck everything right yeah the
joint you sucked the [__] knee joints
elbow joints you suck everything suck
all the join me eat the turtle do you
eat it like the way you suck on a crab
like every little hole but the the shell
becomes soft when they cook it so you
don't have to like it's not like an
exoskeleton yeah also they probably slow
cook it then the whole thing is like
really it looks it's screaming the whole
time they probably braise that it looks
like when people make like a turtle
shaped cake and they slice the cake oh
it's a cake
is that you're like
you're like subturtle out and it was
good like you eat the organs and all
that I no that's already scraped out in
a weird way yeah it's like filleted kind
of yeah when I used to live with Bart's
dad he would have a big pot of soup that
I could always eat isn't that the shower
huh
I have my dad's house and then he had
turtle in there I I I I pulled it out
and then a turtle head came out and I
just dumped that [__] back and I went to
my room yeah
have you ever been somewhere else and
you saw warning signs that you're about
to have a whack-ass meal
I had a different experience because
when I stayed in a place like that I had
some of the Obama [__] ever where my
osmong people yeah Hmong food yeah it
was Hmong they had like I never had Monk
food they had these [__] it was like
these rice Mochi cakes right that they
would Grill on this open fire and then
that would make it soft like like
stringy and then they would get um they
they had like honey with [__] bees
like still dead inside of the jar oh
that's a Jurassic Park and then they
would dip we would dip it in the honey
so it was like imagine Mochi crispy on
the Outside Inside is like it's like
purple rice with honey that [__]
have you guys had Chef boy or do you
spaghetti
you're getting another [__] one no
not SpaghettiOs the spaghetti that
shit's [__] whack too
dude